this book
is actually seeded probably 10 years ago
when i realized oh no a lot of these
kids think it's cool to be mean because
steve jobs was considered mean and i
remember thinking man if i ever get to
as big as i think i'm gonna get and not
that i'm steve jobs now but like i have
enough attention i really want this book
to go viral because i wanted to change
the temperament of leaders
[Music]
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
gary vaynerchuk welcome to the show bud
thank you for having me my old friend
oh they call me old i am but you look
great
gorgeous
nice to see your face again uh
on on the screen here it's been a little
bit uh you've been you've had a lot
crack on lately first congratulations on
christy's that's a huge deal dude
thank you gary v and christie's like man
i thought i had you on phillips depuy i
did an auction a long time ago and now
you're just rolling in
off the top turnbuckle at christie's uh
congratulations that's in the nft world
um but before we go to nfts you got a
new book that's coming out man and i
don't want to beat around the bush
because i'm
i think this is your best work yet and
i'm curious
uh if you could tell us a little bit
about it and why you wrote it
first of all that's like so huge to hear
from you because i know you well enough
to know what that statement means and
it's funny i've been quietly and i
haven't been publicly so talk about
you know
why i admire you i think you have a
really good read on this i do think that
the only book that was like this was
crush it
yeah i felt crush it you know much like
many people's first album right yeah you
have your whole life to write it so
i had quote unquote a lot of things to
say and new things to say and
during a time of transition in the world
you know the economic crisis social
media
so
this
i really got into my feelings in a
different way and really asked myself
like what is it that allows
the insanity of like
the christie stuff the uh you know um
when you're 45 and now you can say okay
i've put more than half my life down in
my professional years
and
boy this is really going well and i'm
happy right it's not just like friends
that we have that have done well
financially but are not happy right we
know that there's a lot of them yeah
there's a lot more of them in the world
believes or knows
and so
you know i
have for over a decade now been
passionate to share and talk
and i feel like you know covid right you
get to get you know you have time to
think and i'm at a different pace and
i think i finally kind of put down
in a really fun format
which was really the thing i was most
scared about like how would i structure
these feelings
and um
i really talk about what i believe which
is
emotional intelligence in business
is the advantage
that being kind
doesn't mean you get walked all over and
you're bad at negotiations
you know that that optimism matters that
accountability pointing a thumb at
yourself versus a finger
especially if you're an owner where you
hired that person so what are we doing
here
you know and so
yeah really i i'm actually do you know
sorry to like throw this in a different
direction but like would love to
understand why you think
that's the case
well
i long have believed much like for
example creativity the things that are
soft and
very difficult to explain often get
written off but i'll give you what i
think is a good analog which is social
media 15 years ago
naysayers were saying that social media
did mean [ __ ]
and what and it was something to write
off but what we
know now is that it was this virtually
the same then as it is now
and
yet the thing that was missing was
our business culture's ability to
measure it
correct as soon as soon as the
technology allowed people to measure it
all the ad dollars came flying out of
television into social media because it
was the fast the most personal the
smartest and everyone knew everything
about it and so it was all of a sudden
what used to be just like literally six
months or 12 months before was just like
oh it's too fuzzy it's social media
became
the [ __ ]
yeah and what what we what i see now is
the same thing it was very easy to
measure a p l or to measure uh you know
someone's performance on these eight
kpis
and yet we've all seen businesses that
have the kpi [ __ ] in the bag or leaders
that check the boxes i can manage a p l
like you know tell the cows come home
but what we can't measure but we know
because we see it in the best leaders
and the best creators and the best
entrepreneurs in the world is emotional
intelligence and i think you've written
the first book that underscores i think
i i wrote that book in creativity and i
think you wrote it i think you wrote it
in emotional intelligence i appreciate
it i'm really proud of it like i really
you know for every listening i created
these scenarios because that's where
everything comes from i'm more of a
listener than i'm a talker which always
you know makes people laugh or freak out
or disagree but i always remind them i'm
like
you only see the content i put out and
post produce very effectively like most
of my day is the consumption of
information
and
a lot of the scenarios are baked in the
at this point hundreds of thousands if
not even millions of dms emails that
i've received over the last 15 years of
this journey and
you know there's just some really
complicated stuff out there right like
stay-at-home mom or dad who still has a
lot of fire in their belly and like what
do you do here and like just all sorts
of fun stuff that i went through and you
know i really talk about accountability
curiosity was a fun one for me to
explore you know i and so i i structured
the book out of these 13 ingredients
that i think really gives somebody a
real shot in the business world and it's
a life book in that way too
i called it 12 and a half because this
one really caught a lot of people off
guard
gary vee
the character the public domain speaker
and pontificator and content creator
very good at candor
too good
um
gary vaynerchuk the ceo and human very
bad at it that's why i called it 12 and
a half
and i called it kind candor my journey
to making kind candor a half from a zero
was because i started calling it kind
candor instead of candor because i saw
back to your point i saw candor for a
long time as an excuse to be mean
i saw candor as something that often
created fear
but what i didn't have yet was the
maturity to understand the vessel that
kander was being delivered in
was the vulnerability
you know my my father was rough with his
candor delivery
a lot of managers that were in that
store were
many people i came across in business in
the 90s and 2000s were
the candor wasn't the problem the the
vessel that was delivering the candor
wasn't kind wasn't empathetic
but now that i've got a better sense
that of that separation
and then i was very self-reflective all
the things that weren't working for me
always pointed back always pointed back
to lack of candor
and um
so yeah i mean i i talk about these
ingredients i talk about scenarios where
three or four of them it's really fun to
show people that ambition and patience
can be played out in the same scenario
people think that's a contradiction
you know and and so i really went i
really went there
you did you did and of course if you're
uh if you haven't included in yet we're
talking about gary's new book 12 and a
half leveraging the emotional
ingredients necessary for business
success but i'm going to add i'm going
to extend your subhead a little bit i
would say business and personal success
yeah that's right you know it's a
business book and we have the same
publisher hollis yeah
and
yet these skills
most of the people who listen to show
are identify as creators entrepreneurs
but the what i've learned is that the
same the same
authenticity transparency the emotional
ingredients that make one successful in
business are
absolutely critical to to to life think
about the relationships that you have
and i'm wondering
did your emotional intelligence
develop because of business or did your
business
acumen and emotional intelligence
develop because of because of
gary the human it's so weird it's such a
fun question thank you
my brain immediately goes into man
it's hard because this was all happening
at six and seven and eight and nine you
know i talk a lot about this
i'm not sure people believe it
this has been a very big theme amongst
my friends and
relatives lately
probably because of the christie's thing
you know you you sit there and you have
an event where like five of your
drawings sell for a million dollars and
and you know and you're up there and
you're out selling pollock and warhol
and you're like what the [ __ ]
and then and then and then you go
through the feelings of like knowing
people are if i'm what the [ __ ] then
many people are like this is [ __ ]
and
i get a lot of feedback from
people i grew up with that are like man
i wish they knew that all you used to do
was doodle in class and on the
chalkboard and you know i was i'm you
know i've come to realize i'm
dramatically more creative than i've
thought about even the way as an
entrepreneur i've always thought of it
as creativity but i thought of it as
strategy
you know even though in the last so many
ways i now see them the same and so
um
you know i think i think for me when i
talk about being a businessman at six
seven and eight there was a piece of
content i put out recently where
you know i do this thing called trash
talk where i go garage sale and i put
out youtube videos to teach people that
it's out there
and i give this
young girl 20 for her lemonade and i'm
walking back to the car and i'm talking
about the reason i did that was that
happened to me when i was 10. some guy
stopped on a bike filled up his lemonade
and he gave us a ten dollar bill and you
know i'm a 45 year old man i was eight
years old so it's ten cents
well it's ten dollars which was like
four thousand dollars it was actually
the reverse right it was ten dollars no
i mean lemonade your lemonade was ten
cents my lemonade was actually maybe 25
cents but we've sold at 10 cents back
then so maybe
and
and
and so you know in the comments just the
amount of it's amazing how cynicism is
so prevalent like that never happened
that never happened and like you know a
couple of my both marissa bird and
robbie turnick who both happened to be
there
were like no that really happened and
something we've talked about for and so
you know it's it's this really fun
journey i've gone on a tangent the
answer is i'm not sure
i've been doing it so
much for so long
i genuinely believe the talent of of
human intuition
was always there
but the refinement of these natural
emotional skills being a leader of my
friends at six like i was to
you know being 14 and being
the son of the father who owned the
liquor store and interacting with
clients and with employees
you know
at 22 i was running the business like
for real so i just think i've you know
at 45 years old i have so much pattern
recognition
and wisdom
of reps from a kid my mom last night
sitting right here
was saying how often i spent time with
80 year olds as a four-year-old
just would gravitate towards it
and so you know it's fun i think i think
um
i think i'm very onto something with
this book i think it's going to really
leave a positive impact this
conversation
and i think i'm going to build an empire
but i'm going to do it with honey not
vinegar
well
that doesn't i i wouldn't disagree
seeing where you've set your ambitions
in the past and what you've been able to
achieve some something that's important
i think to establish in this
conversation and i know we're one of the
earlier podcasts you've done in support
of your new book i want to get firmly on
the table that this
is that these are
these are skills that are trainable and
practicable and once you have the
awareness the
the understanding of what it is you're
trying to cultivate that you can
actually do this so if someone sees
themselves as not emotionally
intelligent or has that
what i would say is a bad habit you
articulated earlier around
packaging candor in a [ __ ] sandwich
because it it is actually under the
guise of like hey i'm going to be direct
you know and then and and though that's
a terrible way of delivering say
feedback that's where you've wrapped it
in kindness so these these concepts are
not something that are removed from
other skills or or the practice if you
will of creativity of understanding that
you're creating and engaging in it so
for the people who don't see themselves
that way would you give them a message
about
what you feel is possible
um
using the ingredients of your book with
the their own emotional intelligence i
think a lot of people are looking for
permission
to bring their
strengths on the eq side to the business
world and i think
i've been doing that but not
communicating it as much and that's why
this is so aha for me this is why
people i deeply admire who i think
consume a lot of content like yourself
will say i think this is the one it
makes a lot of sense to me because it is
in the same way crush it was the one it
was like i was uncomfortably right in
that book which is like hey
you're gonna be able to make money not
by having a job and not by having a
startup and like the creator economy is
ungodly
exactly the way i laid it out same here
i don't think
it's going to be uncommon for people to
believe that empathy and kindness
and patience
are like the alpha [ __ ] not sharp elbows
not negotiation like when i hear things
like don't take it personal it's just
business i'm like what part of cruelty
is acceptable in any scenario
right when i think about people not
realizing the world's abundant and
actually want to tear down other
people's
like you can't imagine how much i want
everything to happen for you and
everybody that looks like you and i
right like like the level of cheering i
have for everybody who's a personality
who might be amassing attention through
content that's why i've always loved
your platform i want everybody on it to
like i don't think like tim ferriss or
kevin rose or arlen hamilton or like
like brook morin like i don't think any
of their attention that they get for
what they do even though it might be
tangentially touching what i do
is taking out of me
no
and i and i want people to i'm very
competitive like this is not about like
like i again i don't know how hardcore
you read it skimmed it got a sense of it
but like this is not written in the
sense of like oh let's be fluffy fluffy
and eighth place trophy like like
tenacity is one of the twelve and a half
there's nothing
soft about tenacity right ambition these
are real things you know but
but i i think people are confused i
think people are confused and then we
had this whole era
and this is where this this book
is actually seeded
probably 10 years ago
maybe 12 when i realized oh no
a lot of these kids think it's cool to
be mean because steve jobs was
considered mean
yeah and i remember thinking
man if i ever get to as big as i think
i'm going to get because i thought it
and not that i'm steve jobs now but like
i have enough attention
and enough success and enough pattern
recognition and have seen it and
witnessed it in enough other places
because it's not a focus group of one
that i feel like maybe this conversation
and i've been doing it quietly in my
social
and i think i really want this book to
go viral because i wanted to change the
temperament of leaders
it's i'm going to do a little full
circle moment here so i'm sitting about
10 feet from when you were
a wine guy
and i'd seen your [ __ ] on viddler
and i had one of the first certainly the
first live show
on the internet and one of the first
podcasts and invited you it was right
after crush it and i believe
uh in parallel to what you're saying
that this
book that you've written here 12 and a
half
rivals the timeliness the uh
vision that crush it did we sat about 12
feet away from here at one moment you
got on my lap which was awesome
[Laughter]
but and we talked about the same thing
about what the future was going to tell
about the moment that we were living in
right there and
uh you or we were i think right on that
and i believe that as i mentioned that
cycle of social media was very valuable
and it became understood that it was
valuable when we could measure it i
think the same thing is true with the
traits that you talk about here there's
an understanding uh amongst the people
who are doing it what what what treat do
you think
doesn't even have to be one of the 12
and a half that you think you've most
gotten better at as simple as that
most you have gotten stronger at
in as your career has evolved
easy empathy
no question my
world view was built very much on hard
charging
you know uh
there's a way and it's my way and you
know as you mentioned
totally and you mentioned being a leader
i've been the you know the captain of
every sports team ever played on
you know
yeah all of those things were true and
ironically and i will say actually sadly
for me that was culturally reinforced
over and over and over of course and
and
when i i remember
started working with my wife kate she
came in was producing these you know
photo shoots in all of the world and we
have very different styles we're very
complimentary and
i was sort of telling her how to get the
best price on the helicopter to fly to
the thing and and you know and my
tactics were just
just like
oh or worse and
she is the
like the kindest sweetest person
in the whole world and i watched her
get
further
negotiate better
have lasting relationships yeah in a
matter
me and my dad my dad
i always you know i always say dad
you're a better negotiator to me but i
don't fully believe it
and i always like and he knows that i
don't
he may win the battle but he lost every
war he might have gotten 50 cents more
off that bottle but we i watched because
i started 14
we didn't not only do we not get good
deals from those wineries anymore at
times
people figured out my dad's game
and i could tell because i was so in
tune that they were starting at higher
price points
right so they made him feel accomplished
in his negotiation
but you know i i think that's right you
know when i talk about this and i want
everybody to hear this
in a world we live in now very
polarizing left right blue red
this isn't about
okay
let's like take the teeth out of
business like this is
very much
a business and life book like for
achievement for success and there is
absolutely
like it's a game it's
the best way i can put is i think of it
like football which i obviously you know
i love a lot surprise
when they play football they beat the
living [ __ ] at each other and they go
hard but when the game is over
and this drives me crazy as a fan
because i'm mad that we lost and i don't
want you to buddy buddy with the other
guy we just lost but they
ask how the wife is i mean i you know
now i'm very into that world they talk
about things like hey i'd love to give a
donation to your charity you'd be blown
away by the stuff that's actually being
talked on the field and you know this
but like you did at a younger level like
this is the professional level and i see
business that way
this is win
let's win but believe it or not back
like your your incredible partner there
you can win
with more hearts than daggers for sure
and to see it in in turn that helped me
deconstruct what she was doing and
recognize
that as soon as you can
you know
experience some of the challenges that
someone else is experiencing and at work
and that realize that they have a boss
and connect around the fact that it's
hard and we're just going to both try
and do right by one another or you know
or some myriad example
you know was very powerful there one
thing i talk a lot about in this book is
optimism if you've decided it's bad it's
already bad
yeah
like you know like they give you this
like cynicism and pessimism is a game
changer for people it is awful it is a
it is a game over before you started
i have room in my life for a lot of
things and in my business for a lot of
things
cynicism is not one of them i i
literally i got i got it
i got no space for it
so
again
the other thing that i want to just say
real quick
that's drock the other day like hey so
what hit you because we just did the
audio book and he was
filmed the making of it then the book
and he's like it's the perspective part
it's when you talk about like
a billion people not having clean water
like it's truly like what i realized in
this book and i didn't really put the
nail in the coffin
but it's very clear to me what i did in
this book the other thing i did in this
book in hindsight was talk about
something i never talk about i'm not
even sure i've articulated this yet in
content so here you go
i
can't
even as i'm about to try right now ever
fully articulate to people
how little i think business matters
there is something
yeah i will i
love what i do i love my process i love
the game i'm all that i appear to be
from a passion standpoint about this
but if
if the concept of business was wiped off
the earth tomorrow
i'm incredibly okay with that
like to me
it just doesn't mean that much and
people have so much pressure
in the workplace especially
entrepreneurs and employees
and like i'm just i realized oh i'm dan
you know they say like a desperate
fighter is a dangerous fighter in a
boxing match
and i feel like
it's really weird to say this this
balance of massive
ambition massive
with equal content
is mind-boggling and a lot of what i
undertone in this book is like you can
eliminate a lot of anxiety
if you realize
what actually matters
well it's been enjoyable watching that
evolve from days where you and i were
putting videos on viddler remember there
was no youtube of course
and i i liked it because
you could like pick which
dot you could see which wine i drank i
mean even when there was youtube i
wanted to be on vidler because i thought
the tagging mattered so much for my
content
yeah and it turns out that that's now
google searching inside of video so that
you can do exactly that what is it it's
15 years later now the fact that we've
been doing this for 15
uh 15 years together is that's a little
bit of a head scratcher and fun for me
the fact that you look younger 15 years
later is the real head scratcher let's
all give this man a lot of love
please leave that comment on social of
how right i am about that
uh well we need to get together again
soon before i let you go man i've got a
couple of things about and i'm going to
read a text that you sent me a short
while ago
chase my man where are you with nfts
and we mentioned your auction at
christie's which is is exceptional um in
in many ways but
i don't think it's separate from this
book and here's here's i'm going to make
the connection and then i want you to
talk about nfts
the connection between the book is
awareness empathy connection these soft
skills historically referred to as soft
but actually are the core
there's just there's a um
like a an awareness of
who you are where the opportunities are
and
you and you are embracing nfts
uh
early and big because they are going to
be so huge um what's
let's let's give a the shortest crash
course that you feel like you can on the
gv lens on nft
asap okay
digital ownership is here
and
that's it
like it's an incredibly simple statement
but it's incredibly difficult for
everybody because we've just gone
through 20 years of non-digital
ownership all of us listening grew up
with 20 plus years of the internet
more
where you didn't own it
as a matter of fact even the people that
own the ip didn't own it so it was the
extreme other way we were all using
creative freedom with all this stuff we
were almost taught that like
people started realizing the attention
was worth more than the actual
monetizing of the
expression it's what hurt major league
baseball they tried to monetize
everything so he couldn't find any of
their content on social except their
channels and the sport decreased in
popularity we all bought into that and
there's an incredible level of truth to
that comma we now have something called
blockchains
blockchains can understand who owns
certain things and we will now start
owning certain things no different than
owning a sheep in farmville
or a outfit in you know fortnite
and the and the things we will buy will
follow the things like mercedes cartier
we will express ourselves through our
ownership i would never flash
a half a million dollars in a bank
account
i will tomorrow flash my proud ownership
of a crypto punk that's how humans work
that's how why we buy art that's why we
do things even if we're not talking
about extreme wealth or wealth or even
middle class wealth let's just talk
about why somebody wants a pair of air
jordans at the end of the day right it's
expression and the same way you care
about a blue check mark whether you do
or not we can all agree many do the same
way you care about following count
whether you do or not i think we can all
agree billions do well that's what's
about to happen with what's in your
wallet and i believe your public wallet
will become a greater insight to who you
are than even the pictures you post on
social because they're less
manipulatable
and so i think this digital ownership
and expression
and then the underlying technology of
nft is where you can transfer leases and
homes and it's it's profound it is
profound it is internet one internet two
this is why it's called internet three
nfts are the biggest thing that's
happened since social 05 or internet 95
and everybody listening
must must
please for your i mean it's not going to
take any skin out of my back but please
if you're listening to this knowing this
audience
please spend 20 hours of real homework
and don't say
no
or
whatever
or nah
say maybe and then build
all right very very uh real world
scenario
ugv give me advice right now on nfts
you need to spend 20 hours so that you
can put out a project and sell some
original photography with access to you
underneath it just to learn
for a man of many words that was pretty
good
you're tightening your program aren't
you
i just it'll be so easy for you because
you care about community you'll
understand that okay i'm going to take
these 25 photos i've never shown anybody
in the world i'm going to nft them i
will whoever buys it i'll give them the
physical print and i will give all 25 of
them an evening a full day with me a
working session and a dinner and i have
a funny feeling 25 people will buy that
nft and by the way i would be one of
those people why i believe in your
career i believe in your future and i
would say to myself oh
i might be able to sell that nft for a
profit in 12 years as he continues to
ascend it's not super complicated
all right what's the uh what's the
insight we've talked about
uh emotional intelligence your new book
12 and a half
nfts i'm trying to use those as just
very cornerstone examples of the work
that you're doing now what is the
thing that is not on
the radar now
that
has that's
that you are equal for me for me
for me it will be long-form storytelling
there is no scenario
of me leaving this
world
without me putting out meaningful
television and film
i just have too many stories that i want
to tell
um
what's the first one going to be
there's a basketball player by the name
of connie hawkins who got banned from
the nba
and i think it's an incredibly important
story because i think it's unjust and so
that's on my mind
um and then and then you know
i'll probably get forced into animation
v friends is insane what i'm actually
doing
yeah and so
you know probably my first at-bat will
be where i am right now in b friends
land an animated film or movie around
patient panda and empathy elephant who i
do think are my woody and buzzier buzz
lightyear you know those are the two
kind of like
alphas of the optimus prime and you know
kind of the
the the alphas in my universe so we'll
see but i have i have a lot
most of what i'm gonna do is gonna sit
under the foundation of these emotional
traits right
like
humanity
man
uh well i've always enjoyed our
conversations i want to keep this one
tight
congratulations on the new book the
christie's thing is huge and if you if
you haven't been following along you've
been living under a rock look that one
up because it's a good one how uh gary
cracked a millie through a christie's
auction
uh with a hand with a
i mean you can't even keep a straight
face it's [ __ ] it's just so real and
and by the way i think by the way on on
the record
let nobody be confused the
laughing is like nervous excitement but
totally but there will be no chance that
that will not be a good investment for
the people that bought it i am going to
build disney i'm going to now
i might you know maybe i pass too soon
maybe whatever but i do believe oh next
30 years that i will make these
characters incredibly culturally
relevant
and
you know i'm obsessed with
over-delivering for everybody who owns a
v-friend nft or the five people that now
own the original art
well i do not doubt that for a half
second i don't think i've doubted you i
do enjoy every once while seeing
our sometimes mutual friends aka like
chris sacca for example talking a little
[ __ ] here and there and then uh
we creators and entrepreneurs have a way
of uh of being right we've been wrong
plenty of times but it's been fun to
watch you've got an outstanding part
about soccer the best part about the way
i like to roll two is we all love to
have hot takes
i think his is a little bit
tongue-in-cheek he's actually i think
just being incredibly nice to me giving
some love to this project
but um
you know it's really really cool to
watch a lot of us evolve over the last
15 years and i'm like excited for the
next 15. i can't wait to see which
solid solid solid acquaintance or friend
or very good friend becomes
governors and presidents and
like you know our generation our
call it 38 to 52 crew is now going into
that next year
and uh i just think it's gonna be a lot
of fun to see how it all breaks out
it is if life is seasons i'm very much
looking forward to the next season uh
there's a lot of a lot of folks that are
in our friend circles and people that uh
those listening and watching now would
know on the internet who are doing
exciting things it makes it uh very fun
to be a part of this show included
appreciate your time always my man we
got lots to connect on uh offline love
you as well man youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee first of all thank you
so much i hope you're doing super well
during these times
i also want to ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and exploration of
youtube is about to explode stories
polls more content more engagement more
surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon
you